two South Texas girls are missing in
Mexico
my daughter didn't just disappear
someone out there knows what happened
Lee wherever you are I'll find you
mostly authorities here in bed with the
cartel who are they look I know your
background Colonel you're playing with
fire you're as bad as it gets beheadings
you promise to keep us safe you didn't
she is out there bro you know I'm there
whenever wherever you let me know Dad
I'm in trouble please
the cartel
came after this
my daughter where is she you're a dead
man
so that's Victor Garza he's got an army
he's Untouchable so what now
do it my way
nobody's getting out of there
[Music]
remember me